okay i'd like to welcome the public to
our
committee of conference here on hb 1661.
we apologize for the ac not working in
this room
it is a little bit hot and warm in here
summer arrived
um
so with that we have a
huge bill in front of us here
so let's start with the community
conference we have today senator
hennessey senator d'alessandro senator
bradley
myself
representative umberger
representative turcotte and
representative cordelli
on this committee of conference
does anybody have any pearls of wisdom
for us before we start
good
we also have a side by side here which
has been handed out has been put
together by jennifer four who is
the researcher for this particular group
and for the house
let's start off right at the top of this
bill and work our way down through it
please
i'm trying to find
okay
so
would everybody be good with just
starting off with the original bill 1661
see if we can agree with that
and
there is an amendment
uh which uh parallels that what happened
is that when we approved this in
education committee in the house it was
approved 19-0
went to the house floor
was
approved on consent calendar no
objections to the cte bill cte bill has
several purposes one
it
aligns scheduling between the sending
schools and the receiving center
we have students missing a lot of days
because calendars are not aligned and we
finally have gotten something together
here to try to help that out and
secondly it allows
students to get pupils to get credit for
the graduation credit through the cte
course or program which they are taking
this has restricted some from
participating in these skill pathways
they have to remain behind in the
sending high school to receive that one
credit they need for carnegie unit to
get out of the school
now they can it's it's going to be
embedded in as a competency in a course
or through that cte program
the amendment which you see there
clarifies
how that
competency is to be approved
we had initially that could be done by
the state board of education as well
that state board is out of this it's up
to the local school district school
board who who approves the graduation
credits for that school district and the
receiving center through the rctea the
agreement to work out
the competencies how they're going to be
uh dealt with that at the center
it's something that's really needed we
worked with the directors they all
were good with that and um
i would like to move amendment
2022 1998
h
is there a second second
we have a motion made to approve
amendment 1998 h
2 1661
made by representative umberger and
second by representative cordelli for
the discussion
uh yeah
thank you mr chair um senator hennessey
is on senate education look okay to you
yes thank you
so i would move the senate concur with a
house amendment
as well as you're all right
i think it's uh
okay so we can concur senate and house
to this amendment to the
main bill
let's move on down
buried in this stuff
okay
yeah we're dealing with now the
legislative parking garage
edition which also came out of the the
house finance and approved by the house
um any discussion on that
i would move that the house asceed to
the senate position of 9.35 million
i would ask that we wait on that i think
we support the parking garage i want to
make it clear but i think that
discussion
um
we may want to talk about
changing the 9.3
if i go ahead if i might um
i believe that the uh
the house thinks that uh
we will have time
uh after the engineering study is
completed and the um
and the work is uh
you know that we're ready to start
building
that there will be ample time
and dollars available
to
build the garage
further discussion
i would just ask we defer on that
i don't see that there's a problem but
okay
so
we're we're good to deferring it and
it's so we were at the place where we're
all accepting of the
i think the the question is is there
some other number the 9.3
that we may want to agree upon
so then let's let's move beyond this now
and get into the remainder of the bills
senator bradley knows where there's some
oil wells
if if i could mr chairman starting on
section 8
that is
my bill senate bill 430
um it is as the
senate passed it
i have spoken with mr williams um
there's
no opposition to
what the house health and human services
committee did and the house finance
committee did
i don't have that prepared as an
amendment but i believe
uh mr williams it was section 29 that
there was just one question about if
nope not section 29 which is the section
we were
would you please come up to the mic
this for the
this this meeting is being streamed
prison lad and senator bradley
we got two minutes
welcome
thank you
um so yes the the department uh
certainly um is fine with the provisions
as passed by the house by both the
policy committee as well as the house
finance committee uh recommendations
however there was a provision with the
caveat
there was a provision in the bill as
passed by the policy committee initially
that dealt with the confidentiality of
information at child protection actions
in court proceedings and under current
law it's a misdemeanor provision for
violating that provision and the house
uh presented an amendment that would
change that to a violation that was the
only item that we were hoping your
consideration as conferees
great uh which section was that john i
believe if you go to the house it's page
17 and section 62 at least as it came
over from the health policy
if you look at the bill it's on page 17
that is correct
and that was section 62 that senator
dell's going to refer to
okay are there any comments representing
turka
thank you mr chairman um
as far as hb430 goes
our sb 430
it is our position right now
that we would want the
house version as amended by the house it
does include
uh a few different uh variations then
the senate version
um
the
one that the house did
pass
was sent to the senate and that bill
was
a non-concur so
um
we
not with the amendment with the floor
amendment
i would i would ask also that this one
uh
this particular issue be put on hold uh
until we've had a sufficient time to
review the side by side just getting the
side by side for the first time and
again the house uh amended version that
was sent to the senate
and non-concurred hat it didn't contain
a uh
floor amendment
at the very minimum thank you mr
chairman thank you mr yes represent our
senator hennessy can i ask what page
uh the representative was referring to
that he wants are you in the side by
side right now
so
i'm on page 26 on that
um
if you were talking about
if we were talking about section 62
within the senate version
no
that's not the section okay that's not
the section
mr chairman if i may yes um
i think we have copies of the
version as passed by the house that
jeremy will be able to pass out here
thank you
believe it's page 24.
okay
so i'm looking at a side by side you'll
be looking at page 24
at the top of that page
a house version
section 62
which deals with uh shall be guilty of a
violation
yes
that is correct it in the center pass
version with all the amendments it's a
different section that's all but
this is the one where there is a
question from the department
they would prefer to keep it at
misdemeanor
further discussion from the community
conference
members
go ahead thank you mr chair um to uh
senator hennessy's question on the
paper that was just passed out
it would be on page 18 down at the
bottom and again i'm i haven't had the
time to look at the entire side by side
i do believe we need more time for that
but at the bottom of page 18 uh section
64 is the amen floor amendment that
the house added and that was the one
sent over to the senate and it was a
non-concur
thank you mr chairman thank you
it appears that we would like to have
more may i think yeah
thank you
um
i guess i'm confused about why
we would want that to be a
misdemeanor rather than a violation
i is
is it
does the department have a response to
that
chairman ladd in response to
representative umberger's question the
current law does provide for a
misdemeanor provision it's been in place
for several years
and it's worked quite well to protect
the confidentiality of the matters
involving abuse and neglect or child
protection matters before
the court it protects the privacy of the
child
the privacy of the family and it's
something that we feel should still
continue to be in place
although it was provided as an amendment
at the house policy committee it never
had
a full hearing on it because it was
determined it was germaine to the
underlying bill and perhaps a more
robust conversation to review
what the consequences could be relative
to changing it from a misdemeanor to a
violation might include
i do recall that there was some
commentary or perhaps confusion that the
application of that statute would only
uh be to either parents or parties to
the action and and not the department
and if you actually have it reviewed by
attorney four you'll see that it applies
to all individuals who are involved in
those actions including the department
of health and services so there was some
misunderstanding in terms of the scope
of this application
also for clarity uh the department as
they stated was fine with the bill as it
was passed by the house policy committee
as well as the house finance i think to
the point of representative turcotte
that there are still some uh issues
concerns around the floor amendment that
was passed in the bill but i'll leave
that to the conferees to discuss that
thank you thank you
i don't think that answered my question
if
do you have another question
uh yes i do
go for it yeah
so
the department thinks that
a misdemeanor
will
change people's
attitude versus a violation is that
is that what you're basically saying
so uh for the record uh john williams
the legislative director for health
immune services and uh the mis the
misdemeanor provisions have been in law
for some period of time and seems to
serve and seem to be serving very well
in terms of protecting the
confidentiality of those proceedings the
concern is if you back off from a
criminal level misdemeanor offense to a
violation which is the equivalent could
be of a parking violation that it would
therefore erode the protections around
the confidentiality for those
proceedings
thank you
answer quencher question no but that's
okay
represent bradley
so is it safe to say
on
the sections of the bill
um dealing with senate bill 430 with the
exception of
section 62
in the side by side we are at least
tentatively in agreement
representative
i can't answer that completely but uh
that is still leaving out section 64
of
of our fl
which would have been our floor
amendment
and section 64 was i think it was house
bill
i don't recall off the top of my head
senator but it's uh it's not like i say
it's on page 18 there starting 64
residential care and health facility
licensing
and
talks about the
facility operating as a membership based
business
that's the paragraph excuse me
and the senate
um killed that bill so we would have an
issue with that
thank you
further discussion from committee
members
so it appears that we are not ready to
resolve this issue right now the
the house is looking at the position as
stated within
the
bill as amended by the house on page
and it appears that the senate's not
on that same wavelength
what about uh going back to the page on
the side by side which is on page 24
dealing with uh misdemeanor verse
violation where do we stand on that
issue i think we would prefer to stay
with a current law
which is a misdemeanor
if there's a violation of
confidentiality that there need to be
some
level
of penalty more than a violation
that's fine with me
okay
before you talk to them
what i would say on that i think we're
going to be probably
recessing till a date in the future to
go over some of these others maybe
that's one
if representative umberger still hasn't
gotten a satisfactory answer on maybe
we can discuss that one within committee
i think that's where we'll go
are there
okay if is there any more discussion on
this part of 1661
may i ask one more question yes mr
chairman
this is for uh hhs
do you have any idea how many
misdemeanors
have been processed for people
not protecting the uh confidentiality
that that is very good question i'm i do
not have an answer for it but i will
endeavor to get you an answer
okay thank you
okay
right um
i guess we are
jumping down to any other areas within
that building next areas which
i don't have that bill in front of me i
just have to be side by side here
left upstairs
yes
i'd just like to confirm with the senate
just to make sure we are all on the same
page that hp 1476 and sb 420 have their
own separate con committees of
conferences and are not part of this
senate bill 6420 has its own separate
committee of conference
[Music]
please remind me what that is
yes
we'll get to bail in a minute i think
right right
but it has its own separate committee
conference that's i just want to confirm
that so that was not part of this
conversation thank you
let's have some conversation
go ahead represent senator
hennessey did you have
i would just ask mr chair we will be
discussing those because they're in here
we will get to 420. yeah thank you
that's where you want to go right
extraordinary needs grant sure yeah
okay
senator turcotte just under senator
representative turcotte just mentioned
that we do have 420
and that is a bill which deals with
exactly what we have here
the house is really of the opinion right
now that we should not be addressing 420
in 1661 but dealing with it in the
community conference on 420.
mr chairman just for senator hennessey's
clarity
sb 420
has its own committee of conference
schedule
so we our position would be we don't
want to make that part of this
discussion and also hb 1476 has its own
committee of conference so that
even though the original
[Music]
your amendment including those since
they have their own committees of
conference they they aren't going to be
a subject of
1661. does that make sense
senator bradley so if i can jump in here
um i had a conversation with the speaker
a couple of days ago
and indicated that i thought the
best place to have a discussion about
bail issues was in the committee of
conference on
1476 so i believe the senate could agree
at this point to
basically take sections
um well it's
um the top of page 24 in the
um senate fast version starts on section
80.
out of
this bill
knowing that their the focus is going to
be on the other committee of conference
and
i think the senate would have cede to
that
off right off the bat so
but i think in terms of senate bill 420
we want to make sure that
uh the underlying bill the
extraordinary grants is
whether it's in this bill or it's in
senator hennessey's bill we want to make
sure that that moves forward in a way
the senate can support
i think that in in terms of addressing
for senate bill 420 through that
committee a conference
we are i don't want to get into the
discussion on that bill right here now
but we are supportive
of the
extraordinary needs grant
but would prefer to discuss that and
take action on that in sb 420 committee
a conference
we we see that there may be a need to
make a minor adjustment to it
uh we can address that in terms of
accountability
which i think i've also spoken to
previously about senator hennessy
that we had discussed way back in 2018
we weren't on board then when we had the
task force led by the representative to
my right
and and i would just since we're
discussing it um
indicate that the problematic subject
matter whether it's in
1661 or 420
is the education tax credit piece moving
to 500 percent of the federal poverty
levels so just so we're all clear
where
the
concern is
i we've also discussed that too and i
think the house is prepared to
look at the education tax credit which
is not part of the you know
of the
uh education freedom account it's not
anything to do with that that where we
would prefer to maybe look at that
incrementally over the next biennium
then
my recommendation would be we just
defer any further discussion on 420
knowing that you're going to have a
committee a conference and it seems like
that's the right place just like 1476 is
the right place for bail
to have those discussions i think we
probably can all agree on that
i think we we agree on that correct
everybody
yes we're with you
okay
so we're taking out of this
amendment
bail
and
those need uh exceptional need grants
is that right assuming we can come to
conclusion on
the committee or conference in 420
the fail situation is a little different
i promised the speaker that we'd have an
up or down committee a conference on
1476 the bail committee conference so
we're prepared to
relinquish that right now
an accurate summation of our of our
conversation
thank you sure
we have a number of the conferees are
going to be on 420 sitting at this table
right now
and i can see that for the conferees
that are sitting from the house side we
are prepared to move forward with
sb 420 the education
extraordinary needs grant
with what we have is we do have a
proposed
amendment that provides accountability
you receive this as the school district
inform the department
what you're going to do with the money
is this the
that's right that's some burger
amendment
you passed out senator hennessy
mr chair
yes
so the amendment that i passed out was
the amendment that representative
umberger had added on the house side
it's a technical fix
versus the accountability fix
so this was we did not add this to 1661
when we added 420 but we should have
the other piece
of 420 the accountability piece that you
had added on the house side um
i i'm familiar with the
this one right here the umberger
amendment dealing with the definition of
equalized valuation per pupil based upon
the free and reduced
we got that and we under we in fact i
believe came out of initially from the
policy side
here in the house okay we're good with
that okay
that what i'm talking about is a another
amendment which we have an ied
i don't believe i have that because we
weren't dealing with it today
the the other piece i believe you're
talking about the
when a school district receives the
grant they have to
show that um
what they're going to use the grant for
and that they've made improvements
senator
would you like me to speak at that about
that mr chairman
i would once again ask that we hold any
discussions on 420 until that committee
of conference i've just passed out the
language which has been we will be
asking that to be part of 420
to you uh it's uh
on this amendment right here which is is
just the language which we stripped out
of what we already had the past as a
house
um and somewhere along the way it got
lost or didn't get pasted in or added on
it's a part roman 2 going down there on
the bottom that page
that was designed if we were going to
add it in 1661 which we are not going to
do
so it would just be from line 17 to 32
on that that would be the accountability
section
mr chairman yes um
from what i heard earlier
my understanding was that
we were in agreement on 1476
bail not being part of this but a
separate committee of conference but any
discussion of the um
sb 420 section of 1661
would be on hold and we would first
address um the committee of conference
for
sb 420
itself is is that that's correct okay i
think we agree to that we that's been
agreed upon okay
we will be dealing with everything
dealing with the extraordinary needs
grant in the committee conference for
420 this was just explaining so that the
senators here would be aware that that's
we're going so we can make a decision on
as to where we're going to go on that
go ahead
if i heard representative cordelli and
senator bradley
that they want according what i'm
hearing from the senate side is that
they want to defer
until after the 420 committee a
conference
is that
is that is that correct
yes
thank you okay so
they're not willing to give it up out of
here
until such time as
the committee conference for 420 is
completed
and that will be on monday
next
i can change it to money but right now
it's tuesday
would you prefer it be monday
actually i didn't set that one
no that was sent by set by senator ward
yep
correct 9 30 monday
9 30 monday
we could agree to that we can agree to
that yeah i i don't see senator i don't
see any problems with that we 420 should
not be hanging this up right now
420 is
looks good to us we agree
okay
so no more discussion on 420 we've got
it
thank you it's on hold until until we
deal with it 9 30 monday morning that's
correct
okay okay
we talked about uh
bale
with 1476.
are we missing a component here 400.
chairman 1476 hb is also has its own
committee contract that's right they've
already agreed we've already dealt with
that right exactly
we have 400 okay we have 400
okay uh representation burger would you
like to discuss that
i'd like to find it
that's what i'm trying to do too this is
the first time i've seen the side by
side jen what page is it on
which page i'm sorry i couldn't hear
38. thank you
okay get in the business of land new
sports zoning and workforce housing and
the likes
uh no i would not like to say anything
other than
uh mr chairman i could certainly we did
have some issues and uh
thank you representative sure um
i have a
piece of i guess they
yeah i guess they match here
um so
going through the bill from start to
finish
starting on section 81
where it talks about the training
we are
good with that
section 82
which talks about the local use board
staff finance
it's another section that we
are okay with
um except for
section four
of 83
beginning with if a municipality allows
that we
we would like to see out
um going down further section 84
and 85.
we are okay with it we'd like to hear
the senate's
take on the 90 days
whether that's adequate too much too
little
going down you're in section 85 now
correct i was yes okay
is there any reaction to the from the
senate regarding the 90 days
you said you're in section 85 page 30
that's correct
powers of joining board of adjustments
i heard you say you're okay with that 84
yes
so anyway you can think about that one
i'm going to continue real quick here
okay you can go back to that 90 day
question
uh
there's a single change in that uh
talking about subject to age restriction
uh we are not in favor of that change
section 87
we are good with
section 88
we are okay with
um getting into section 89
we are not
uh
we would like to see out only because
what there is a uh
a bill in interim study that we believe
is a better place
to work that section of it i don't have
the uh the bill number on that interim
study but there is one that exists you
guys may know what it is
going over to the next section 91
well what about 90. did i miss one you
jumped over 90
90.
hold on
yeah i that uh
89 and 90 are both contained in that uh
the interim study bill so that would
also be a no
do you have the you said you didn't have
the interim study i don't i can get it
for you okay
somebody may know that
uh section 91
we are okay with
okay
and
we are not okay with
dessert and 94 is also known within 92
and 93 other specifics that or it's just
the sections okay go ahead 92 93 and 94
and then that gets us to the end
okay
thank you mr chairman
thank you
for taking us through that
would the senate like to discuss any of
those areas that we have just walked
through that there may be some
difference
or do you need time
um
all right so why don't we start at the
top which would be
section 85
um
is there an alternative proposal to 90
days
not looking so much for a proposal we
were just trying to get your
understanding of why 90 what rather than
60 or 120 just
an explanation i don't think we're
really
hung up on it i think the proponents of
the bill felt that it was workable
within a 90-day time frame to
begin formal consideration and approve
or disapprove i mean obviously the
point is to try to move through the
process for workforce housing so
90 days was
the way um it was proposed to us by the
advocates and the governor
i don't think we'd be be opposed to that
right
so the next section
uh the workforce housing definition hang
on let me
get back to merging both
here
uh representative
can i just ask a question on the side by
side um
where is the section
maybe i'm missing something that
um
equates
uh workforce housing to
incentives for elderly housing
i in the senate version of the bill it's
section
i believe 83.
top of page 40 maybe
yes i have it in
okay
so
if i could ask why
uh representative turcotte
you want that deleted
because i think from our point of view
this is
one of the most important pieces of
the entire bill
yeah i i believe uh under that paragraph
senator that um
the definition is amended
not that whole section removed
and it's
uh it was only to the
subject to age restriction that that we
had the issue with uh with
and
make sure i read this correct
i will is is that the part you were
asked about this the age restriction
itself
if so i'm gonna have to get back to you
when we reconvene to give you the exact
response as to why i think it was
section
the senate version and
yeah that's horrible
and that's what you want out and that's
why i'm trying to understand that
thank you
representative you thinking that that we
need to get back on that
yeah that's what i said before yeah i'm
going to have to get back to you on that
one exactly
senator d'alessandro did you have
yes okay
later yep
age
page 42
is the next one that's where i am yeah
so we're at right now the top page 42
and the side by side here
um
we're that's being done by interim study
now you said representative
yes uh representative cordelli found the
bill that's actually hb
1389 and it was a bill entitled superior
court land review
and that entire section
according to house majority leader
osborne is
who's also a co-sponsor of 1389
we believe that is better handled in in
that bill
or a similar bill
and that's applicable to part 92
yes okay
so uh if i could ask your question
representative turcotte i think you said
you're okay with
section 87
and you're okay i believe with section
88 yes yes okay thank you
all right and then we get to section 89
which
i think is pretty important section
for expedited review in the courts i
mean obviously
um
you know trying to get things
done and accomplished
is there
um
maybe some common ground that we could
get to with
slightly longer timeline on this
again senator that that section there is
uh
the section i referred to in uh house
bill 1389
um
and representative osborne does believe
that
we could handle that section 18 section
89 and 90 better
in uh in that venue that bill
so you're seeing the next biennium
exactly
okay
again i guess i'd ask the same question
on section 92.
i think
if i
wrote it down correctly that that was a
section
you're proposed to striking
proposing to strike
that that is correct
yes
3 and 94. that's correct
need some more you got some more
anything else
i would just say i think going back it
was section 83
um obviously you're going to get back to
us but i would just highlight that that
the workforce housing and the elderly
housing that is
um pretty important to
myself and i think all the senators too
um
so hopefully we can find a way maybe
some of these other sections are of
lesser importance but that one is very
important so just for your consideration
83 was that
yeah senator
we're talking section 83 right now it's
very important to the senate
are there further comments on this
representative
uh no sir thank you
from the senate
it seems to me we should you know think
about this over over the weekend and
talk amongst
ourselves
and i would concur with the senator and
i would i would also add um
and i can't remember the sections in the
original bill i think it was section 4
and 16 of senate bill 400
um that dealt with inclusionary zoning
and the champion award
um
understanding i think we had heard
that there was opposition on your side
to that
and there was some opposition from
the municipal association
to those two sections senate dropped
those already
so they're not in
the senate version of
this amendment on 1661.
okay if there's no further discussion
on this right now what we need to do is
identify the time which we're going to
come back together and meet
at a later date
thank you go ahead represent ambergris
yeah the only question that i have is on
um
all the stuff for hhs
they had said that they wanted to go
back to misdemeanor
um
and
i was just asking why i don't have any
problem with that change
i don't know if
anyone else in the house
oh
i just said the the the uh
the violation versus the misdemeanor
that i had i had no problem with that i
think uh
hhs was going to get back to us with any
numbers on um
misdemeanor
issues that had been
found
well that was true
okay i think mr williams may have more
you're you're welcome to come up again
we never see you in education but i see
in the hallways
thank you very much um so with some some
assistance uh because it also involves
us looking uh at
it also involves us looking uh working
with uh collaboratively with others uh
the information i've been provided is
that they're uh within approximately the
last decade there were two incidents
where there was at least primarily a
charge arising from that statute it was
converted to another charge eventually
uh but both of the two uh charges that
were brought forward under it uh
died a uh um in the process they were
either uh no proster they did not make
their way to an actual conviction so uh
the numbers were two charges apparently
and then um none of them resulted in
conviction
which which may speak volumes of the
fact because it is a criminal offense
and it shows the importance of
confidentiality relative to child
protection
cases if you are to reduce it to a
violation it's just something for the
committee to consider in terms of it
seems that the law is working currently
in terms of at least charge violate
charge offenses for that as a
misdemeanor
thank you thank you very much
certainly we'll take that into
consideration
okay
any further discussion on 1661 now
before we
represent hennessy do you have days
which are good for you or to meet
let's try and get something here
it took me an hour today just trying to
schedule one meeting
thank you for the question
how about
11 a.m on monday
or noon
you should be done your education
meetings by
they're going half hour in lengths
i understand
is monday
good or you're looking
11 30 is the new proposal
[Laughter]
11 looks good for me
or 11 30.
we're talking monday
11 30 is fine with me
any
how about lou
jeb
okay we will we'll set the next one for
11 30 on the 16th
hopefully we'll have air conditioning by
then
hope
anything further for representative
burger
yes let's just be clear
what
we need to come back on monday for okay
okay
we've got some issues with
which is
all of that
um
on
all of the
stuff for hhs
we had one problem there
the
senate had a seated to the house
but we still need to solve that problem
is that correct i think
that we just need an amendment
to reflect the
house version
from your committee and representative
pearson's committee
which the department has agreed to so i
think on 400 the only issue
is whether we're going to change to a
violation versus a misdemeanor
i believe that's the only issue
for us
and will accede to
everything
representative umberger that the house
did and then
just try to iron out that one issue of
misdemeanor violation
okay yeah if
if i i also understand
i know you basically um
i tl
the house
position uh
is that right or wrong yeah
except i don't know
but anyhow um
we did have an additional
amendment that was
uh part of the um
house
position
and did you want to go over that
uh representative
no we already spoke about that a little
earlier and uh
senator bradley mentioned that he
thought they were
unable to
go with that that is the amendment like
we talked about before
um hb430 we sent uh sb430 sorry
uh that we sent to the senate and that
was non-concurred and that's how the 430
ended up attached to 1661 the senate
version okay so i apologize but i can't
remember what that bill was 10 40
10 44
10 44 yes that's what we non-concurred
with that sounds thank you pretty good
you have all the information you need
rips and umber
that we can get today
and we're going to um
we're holding on the parking garage if
i'm not mistaken so
we need to uh
come to grips with that before monday
is there any
issue with the parking garage
i didn't hear there was any issues
regarding the parking garage there isn't
it's the dollars associated with the
parking garage as i understand it
and
that's a
discussion
i think representative albert and i
might want to have an offline
conversation about this
yeah yeah
we have 9.35 million there in in that
bill
so that's where we'll leave it for today
and you can have that discussion
represent amberger with uh senator
bradley okay
okay
so we've got
what one amendment to do
on hhs
is that correct
i think what
maybe the easiest way to
resolve this is if you're a very able
committee
um
assistant researcher researcher comes in
with an amendment that reflects
the house version of
um
senate bill 430 as approved by both the
house hhs committee and representative
umberger's committee
then will
decide on violation or misdemeanor but i
think everything else is good to go
so if we had that amendment we should be
able to
resolve that on monday
so you'd fold in this amendment right
here regarding the cte
with the other okay
okay yes sir
i see your mic on down there
representative do you have anything okay
okay you're good
okay
so it looks
is
okay thank you so much
here
so we'll recess this meeting until
monday morning at 11 30
here in the same location
thank you
you